hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - I went a little
crazy but I'm going to make sure that I
finish this game you saw that right
just make it ha ha ha ha ha ha ha for
you oh I'm over heal but I got so many
and that's another one ha ha oh what's
that
no don't think so John oh oh that didn't
hurt at all I'll use another fun time I
met kids ha ha ha look mo my favorite in
the world going ha ha ha you know
treasures gosh that's hilarious more
ammo
I love ammo it's the only Emma I need
not ha ha Oh baby
hello I look like a lord help again
better bill back up
oh we're all dead oh oh just making my
way along to get by as well as I can
come and open up ah
you hit me that's surprising but not
that surprising
it's obviously I'm terrible
thank you hello big guy nope not today's
super needy rule Oh
of course I miss hahaha oh no at all no
Thank You Emily
you stay there for a moment we gotta
collect all this ammo better heal again
ah oh he's on me that's hilarious
oh the problem of unlikely
yay he'll again oh just run away so fun
how much ammo would I have left only
oh hello friend what are you doing there
you silly goose Oh such good times I
have with me and my buddy ah yeah lock
it up and then open it up and I'm right
here it's the end hello bright light Oh
guiding me on my way oh oh oh no matter
mash me my pop filter but it doesn't
matter what the hell what why I was
mashing 2 e ah it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter at all why would it
matter
it really was nationally don't imagine
the dumb ashes there we go not in the
neck oh that didn't hurt you and your
Chaplin gun think you can beat me oh the
things written on your forehead
Oh marker symbols are written
before it that's weird hahaha oh oh poor
little gaga boom
what the hell what I went right on him
it doesn't matter
ha I'm terrible with the javelin gun
anyway haha I'm only good with one
weapon baby fun time
oh what's that
I love you too baby
oh hello baby
yeah hahahahaha better here love hello
hi baby
every load will get full ammo for when I
destroy your marker
reload ah they're giving me ammo my
favorite gun better heal up again
Oh better get away I want to touch you
lady got the her pretty herb oh that
hurt - ah
ah
okay after a sit-down
I want to get out of there as it's kind
of going off yeah I know you're sad
Nicole was kind of a [ __ ]
oh holy [ __ ]
wait no this can't be right
what
I do something wrong not haha
did I do something that's that's a laugh
complain about it we often died yeah
well here's another one I'm crashing
through the roof to get you know it's
too late sit through the station you
know you don't really have to say this
time ha ha ha yeah holy crap is that the
marker
it's built kind of weird oh you're not
gonna know down here oh I get it I get
to fly to her yeah baby
I'm coming I'm coming bit boost mood Oh
big pieces of debris I didn't know fit
ah
ain't no thing Wow oh yeah I'm coming
aah aah made it
aha I knew it I knew is gonna be eat huh
I'm there yeah an old baby
I'm shutting it well not soon but Justin
just long enough to see the explosion
yes ah no it's beauty
oh this looks familiar
Elly was dead the whole time she's out
there
Oh oh man oh man
that was a great game I kind of went a
little crazy there but I just wanted to
I just wanted to make sure that I got
through it so surprisingly that was that
was a little farther back then I wanted
that that score to be but it's
understandable if I'd known what the
Indigo was going to be like it I would
need that many health kits I would have
gone first and I did the polls rival
just because I tried every single other
gun in the game and I've been holding
off intentionally on the pulse rifle and
I knew I knew I had that whole shot
everything would going
you saw how easily that pulse fed just
rip things apart like it's better at
cutting things apart than the plasma
cutter is and it's driving flyer a
little more there just all around you're
right
so anyway I love this series it's like I
mean I absolutely love the dead space if
they're the two games that played their
phenomenal games this one I asked for
the beating I got really I asked for all
so I can't fault the game at all for all
the times I died at kudos to you
anyone can count up how many times I die
but either way
excellent excellent game beyond a team
and tabbies and um coming up real soon
we'll never get a chance I'm going to do
a live stream of hardcore hardcore mode
of this and I'm only going to give
myself one life I'm gonna go until I die
I'm gonna get everything to my advantage
I'm gonna do a New Game+ hardcore mode
only get one life and I'm gonna do
whatever game I want what's the most
like gonna be the pulse rifle just go
through it and just beat the crap out of
everything as far as I can on one life
ignoring the three save rule if I can't
beat the game on one life that's it for
me so stick around for that all
announcin I'm at least at least the same
day if not dated but thank you everyone
for watching this it's been probably the
longest game
I've let down lets play out thank you
everybody for watching and that's all I
got to say about that hope you enjoyed
this game
hope you enjoyed everything about it cuz
I should go out and play go on buy it
it's a great game it was $5 on Steam the
summer sale is coming up I'm sure that
it's gonna come up for $5 again so thank
you again everybody who watch I
appreciate every single one of you so I
will see you in the next game
bye bye